que jean jacques kourliandsky chercheur
à l'iris et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france oui pour soi bonsoir l'amérique
latine est loin de nous est ce que
l'amérique latine subira ou subit en ce
moment aussi de plein de plein fouet
cette crise de plein fouet pas encore il
ya un décalage d'un mois par rapport à
l'europe
alors il ya eu beaucoup de questions il
ya quelques semaines tout le monde se
demandait bien pourquoi ils couronnent
un virus il n'y a pas de cas en afrique
et en amérique latine y avait toute une
série d'explications
les explications les plus cohérentes
guen certainement ont fait que seul le
mexique des liaisons aériennes directes
avec la chine mais ensuite avec
l'explosion de de la maladie en italie
là effectivement beaucoup de pays ont
des relations aériennes régulières avec
l'italie on a vu que progressivement la
maladie le virus pénétrer dans les pays
d'amérique latine
le premier décès enregistré a été un
décès en argentine le 7 mars donc c'est
assez récent et actuellement donc on
assiste comme comme on l'a vu dans en
europe une augmentation progressive du
nombre de personnes affectées du nombre
de décès avec des gouvernements qui
réagissent de façon différente d'un pays
à l'autre
donc le pays qui à l'aller les les
réponses et les moins responsables pour
l'instant c'est le nicaragua est le pays
qui a effectivement les pays qui ont eu
les réponses les plus
dur à dire et c'est le chili le pérou
l'argentine pour l'instant mais on le
voit c'est comme en europe finalement
avec un temps de retard les pays
réagissent chacun à leur manière ils
seront également touchés de la même
manière vous le disais mais avec un
temps de décalage
alors tous les pensées les chiffres sont
toujours à prendre avec certes un
certain recul donc l'aider c'est donc
effectivement là il n'y a pas de
contestation possible sur l'évaluation
des cas il semblerait que les pays les
plus affectés
sous réserve effectivement que tous les
cas sont bien identifiés c'est le brésil
qui aurait plus de 600 ans entre 600 et
700 malades du coronavirus suivi du du
philly qui aurait 342 cas puis
l'équateur et le mexique
est ce que le tourisme est arrêté ou pas
dans ces pays
pardon est ce que le tourisme est arrêté
par oui alors oui par exemple en
république dominicaine qui est un pays
qui vit du tourisme donc la république
dominicaine a suspendu non seulement les
vols en direction d'europe mais
également l'accostage des bateaux de
croisière en revanche cuba mais qui est
dans une situation très particulière
compte tenu du blocus économique des
états unis et cuba qui a besoin du
tourisme se contente pour l'instant de
contrôle sur les voyageurs venant des
pays européens affectés qui constitue un
des flux important de visiteurs et de
touristes qui se rendent dans ce pays
est très très court il nous reste une
minute
évidemment dans certains pays qui ont
beaucoup de difficultés économiques on
sait comment ça va se passer est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire face bien alors
c'est la raison pour laquelle entre les
deux grandes économies d'amérique latine
le brésil et le mexique sont également
des pays qu'ils prennent des
les mesures minimales en dépit de la
suspension des vols qui a été prononcé
et en direction des vols pour provenance
d'europe et d'asie et par le brésil
aujourd'hui mais pas les vols en
direction des états unis n'ont pas été
suspendues le mexique n'a pas pris de
décision importante en vue de juguler le
coronavirus bon c'est ses 7e retard à
l'allumage je dirais comme pour essayer
de bloquer l'épidémie et du très
certainement difficultés qu'ont ces pays
en ce moment notamment en ce qui
concerne le mexique mais aussi le brésil
qui sont affectés par là la baisse de la
demande chinoise qui sont la chine est
le deuxième partenaire commercial du
mexique est le premier du brésil et
l'effondrement des prix du baril de
pétrole
donc couper l'arrivée de revenus liés au
tourisme
bon c'est fait c'est une mesure
extrêmement difficile que vont
certainement être obligé de prendre et
l'autre des deux pays mais je résiste
encore en arriver jusque là merci
beaucoup jean jacques kourliandsky
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france